[Musik]
ein sonntagsfrühstück aus papier trauben
aus glasperlen fleisch aus gemüse ein
gehirn aus wolle und ein kopf ganz aus
lebensmitteln die deutsche illustratorin
sarah illenberger liebt das spiel mit
dem ungewöhnlichen alles in ihrer umwelt
ist für sie inspiration und werkstoff
zugleich so wird der wocheneinkauf
unweit ihres berliner ateliers
automatisch teil ihrer arbeit
ich liebe dich alle materialien aber
irgendwie angetan und das ist so
vielseitig ist und die farben auch so
kräftig sind und dass man auch immer
wieder so ein überraschungsmoment hat
weil man nicht weiß was man bekommt ein
organisches material
ein atelier im berliner stadtteil
wedding hier springt sarah illenberger
den rahmen des klassischen grafikdesigns
ihre arbeiten illustrieren situationen
für anzeigen magazin strecken und freie
kunst flach sind sie im wahrsten sinne
des wortes nie eine 3 d illustratorin so
könnte man sie beschreiben
sarah illenberger arbeitet an der
schnittstelle von kunst grafik und
fotografie
ihr hauptinteresse gilt den analogen
handwerk aufgewachsen ist sie in münchen
die mutter schmuckdesignerin der vater
szene wird angefangen
ich gehöre zu der generation von kindern
die ohne fernsehen oder zumindest mit
wenig fernsehen und ohne computer und
digitaler welt aufgewachsen ist unsere
gab es genügend zeit und raum um mit dem
vorhandenen material irgendwie zu
basteln und lustigerweise hatte mein
vater im restaurant als ich so 45 war in
münchen und sein das lager von dem
restaurant als des essens lager war so
mein spielplatz deswegen glaube ich habe
ich immer noch so ein bezug zu
lebensmitteln
nach einem grafik design studium in
london gründet sie mit ihrem damaligen
freund in münchen ein schmucklabel
schnell gerät sie hier an ihre kreativen
grenzen
sie beginnt sich mit ihren
dreidimensionalen grafiken bei magazinen
zu bewerben mit großem erfolg
mittlerweile zieren ihre arbeiten
titelblätter in der ganzen welt
[Musik]
ich glaube sobald man sachen halt mit
der hand an fest und und seine eigene
energie reihen schließen lässt dass
daraus auch was anderes entsteht was
vielleicht auch menschlicher und um
nicht so perfekt oder in perfekter ist
und ich glaube das interessiert mich
einfach mehr als die perfekte
zweidimensionale computeroberfläche es
sarah illenberger stil funktioniert auch
auf großen flächen regelmäßig gestaltet
sie in deutschland die schaufenster der
französischen luxusmarke hermès sie
liebt herausforderungen ihre arbeiten
sollen von allen seiten gut aussehen
für ihre großprojekte arbeitet sie gerne
mit künstlern oder handwerkern zusammen
in kooperation mit einem berliner
schreiner entstehen überdimensionale
schreibtisch utensilien ebenfalls
bestimmt für einen auftrag von hermès
meine karriere fing eigentlich mit einem
großen scheitern an ich habe in der
design agentur gearbeitet und wurde noch
drei wochen entlassen
meine aufgabe war es so eine miete sein
für seine opern magazin zu machen und
der kreativdirektor sich mein ergebnis
an und meinte es wäre leider überhaupt
kein stück besser als das ursprüngliche
heft und so bin ich dann gegangen und
habe aber von diesem kreativ doch was
schönes mit auf den weg bekommen und
zwar meinte er dass meine mappe mehr wie
ein zauberkasten aussieht als jetzt eine
klassische die seiner mappe und ich
möchte mir keine sorgen machen irgendwas
wird schon aus mehr nicht irgendwas ist
aus sarah illenberger geworden sondern
eine der erfolgreichsten
illustratorinnen europas deren
unverwechselbarer stil weltweit gefragt
ist
[Musik]